- [Instructor] How did
Ronald Reagan's policies
affect the government and economy?
- What Ronald Reagan believed
is that good programs,
he had been a New Deal democrat,
he believed that what had happened was
good programs that had
tried to help people
who needed the help, the
poor, the infirm, the elderly,
those programs had ballooned,
and what had happened was
they were no longer prioritizing help
to those who needed
it, but they had become
a kind of system where those
who made the loudest noise
got the most government,
got the most money
and got the attention from the government,
and that that in fact stopped
helping people in need
and ended up hurting
people, ended up sort of
entrapping them in government dependence.
And so what he said was he was
going to do two big things.
Or three big things actually.
He was going to cut taxes,
and what that was going to do
was shrink the amount of available money
towards government, which
he was then going to also do
by cutting spending, and he
was going to cut regulation.
So it was essentially
paring down government,
which he thought was inefficient towards
giving resources to those who need it,
he wanted a lot of that power
to go back to the states,
and he also believed
in an economic program
that both cut money from domestic spending
but also cut taxes, which he believed
would actually generate more revenue
because of something called
supply-side economics,
and so his both economic theory
and his theory about shrinking government
were kind of matched
up in his first budget
and in his first major tax cut.